Hello everybody, Dr. Kevin Connors here with another 60-second cancer update. Just recently,
Monsanto, our good friend, right, was just slept with another giant lawsuit. This is actually
the third lawsuit of people who have, uh, are making claims that the cancer is caused by
road-up. So, road-up is their major weed killer. That's in just about everything, though,
and our food supply, and this couple was actually a couple who both had done Hodgkin's Lephoma,
a $2 billion lawsuit. I mean, this could be, these lawsuits keep coming. They could be a bankruptcy
for Monsanto slash bear, who bear, who bought Monsanto out. Big time, really bad for you. If you're
still using road-up, you guys, you have to stop. Well, nothing else kills the weeds, like that does.
I started using this formula last year, and it's worked well. It doesn't work as good as
road-up, but I haven't used road-up for a very, very long time. But using your old homemade weed
begun with vinegar at some salt and done dish soap has been great for us weed around those cracks.
Don't use road-up, stay away from this stuff. Even if you're not afraid of cancer, it causes so many
horrible disruptions and intercured disruptions that it's just so bad for you in so many ways.
Start using something natural. All right. If you want more information, you can find it on our blog,
or on our website, cuttersclinic.com. Thanks.